today we're going to be looking at the  hardest maiden one in all of chess  here we go it's white to move in this  position and every move seems like  checkmate but only one move  actually is we'd love to play d8 queen  but guess what  that's illegal we would love to take  this bishop with checkmate except guess  what  that's not checkmate either is this  checkmate no  no it's not why not cause i go king f8  is this checkmate  no there's rook g5 is this checkmate no  you lost your  queen so white to move here there's only  one checkmate see if you can find it  of course the move is queen a3 and now  due to the pin on the queen this queen  check cannot be stopped the king cannot  go this way the king cannot go this way  the king cannot go any of these  directions and it  is officially checkmate for black  my name is national master caleb denby  let me know in the comments if you like  this video  and as always subscribe for more